there is one name that you're not
allowed to say in politics you know his
name that is
with george soros
you're gonna talk about you might be
kicked off of social media you're not
allowed to say george soros because if
you mention the name george soros
you are
an anti-semitic conspiracy theorist if
you just even say the name
because some conservatives have
previously observed that george soros
is a huge funder of very far left-wing
causes
and a huge funder of democrat
politicians and that he's exerting a lot
of his influence to destroy our country
but you see george soros is jewish
and so if you
ever mention that you're an anti-semite
and you're a conspiracy theorist too
because i guess george soros doesn't
really give any money it's a total
boogie man it doesn't oh wait a second
we've got
we've got federal
documents here from the election
commission showing
that george soros
has donated just year to date just to
one super pac
125 million dollars
that's
that's a lot of money 125 million
dollars i'm seeing it just year to day
just to one super pac
just for
to promote left-wing causes
but i thought that was a racist
conspiracy theory i am now pretty
convinced
that when the liberal establishment
calls something a racist conspiracy
theory
you can be almost certain almost not 100
but almost certain
that that observation is true
because racist
for the left racist doesn't really mean
racist well they've changed the
definition of racist the anti-defamation
league changed the definition just
within the past
few weeks
from
hating people based on their race to
only something that white people can do
against non-white people so they change
the definition frequently but it really
doesn't even have that much to do with
race racism
what racism means in the modern leftist
parlance is
bad
just bad if you're a racist if i say
you're a racist all that means is you're
bad
really all it means is i don't like you
because the left doesn't even
generally believe in objective truth
they just believe that politics is a
system of interests we're all just
trying to club each other on the head
and there's no logic or transcendent
moral order so it just means i don't
like you
okay so that's what racism and then
conspiracy theory
in modern leftist parlance
means something that will be proven true
in nine months
so
something i don't like that will be
proven true in nine months is
is what they're talking about and that
would seem to be the case
when we're talking about the influence
of someone like george soros when we're
talking about
the origins of kovid when we're talking
about the effectiveness of mitigation
measures when we're talking about on and
on
and on and on i really hate being lied
to
i'm sure you hate being lied to as well
and did you know that when you go to the
grocery store and you buy your meat
you very often see a sticker that says
product of usa did you know that 85
percent of the grass-fed beef in the
united states is imported from overseas
did you know that that product of usa
sticker means basically nothing as long
as there's minimal processing here you
can be importing cheap beef from from
foreign countries and they'll call it
american beef don't do it don't don't
buy that cheap imported beef that lacks
true good american flavor check out good
ranchers
all their steaks are usda prime and
choice grated means the steakhouse can
come to your door i had some delicious
rib eyes
not last night two nights ago
from from good ranchers they were
absolutely fabulous grilled them up to
perfection right now you can save this
is not a joke
thirty dollars with my code knowles
canada wlis at checkout 30 that's a lot
of money off any box biggest discount
they've ever offered today is the day to
save big on your new favorite steak they
are the exclusive meat company of the
daily wire for good reason go to
goodranchers.com knowles to save 30
bucks make 2022 your most flavorful ear
yet good ranchers american meat
delivered hey oh
thanks for checking out that clip that's
cool man nice to be with you if you want
more clips
ring the bell subscribe leave a five
star review on apple podcast spot if i
stitch your google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts get it here at
youtube get it at the daily wire get it
on your audio podcast app get it
anywhere you can
to stave off the sensors we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you